now we're here to give you an exclusive
first look at resident evil village
gameplay
just like in resident evil 7 biohazard
you'll be taking control of ethan
winters
you'll make your way from the village to
the castle
players will need to get in and search
for their kidnapped daughter
as you've noticed by now resident evil
village keeps the first person
perspective
we think it really draws players into
the detailed world we've created
you'll see a lot of those little details
come to life here
the team put a ton of effort into
creating a truly authentic feel
from art design to technology everything
ties in great and creates some beautiful
visuals
now it's time to meet some of the castle
denizens
as you'd expect a warm welcome is not
really what's in store breezy
let's take a look at him wow well ethan
winters
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
shifting gears a bit we're finally going
to show off some combat
it's not just about shooting
guarding will also be an important part
of the game
each type of enemy has their own
distinct way of fighting so you'll need
to change up your strategy to defeat
them
everyone knows what to do with red
barrels right
some of you will remember a similar
management system in resident evil 4.
this time around we've added crafting
which allows you to create items such as
first aid and ammo
[Music]
there's also an assortment of weapons to
find and utilize throughout the
game i've been waiting for you mr
winters
how do you know my name
anyone who is anyone has heard of the
likes of you the merchant makes a return
this time he's known as the duke
you'll be going to him to buy and sell
weapons amongst other things
the director wanted to give him a unique
look and you'll often find him in
different situations each time you
encounter him
he's an interesting fella
smash away with your trusty knife
there's plenty of items to find in your
trap
wait
do you hear that
and we've also got extra objectives
outside of the main ones
of course it goes without saying that
there'll be plenty of puzzles to solve
for players to move forward
oh and uh
plenty of surprises to keep you on your
toes
[Music]
i haven't cut open a man in a while
let me stream
slice your jugular and just watch
well that's one way to end the video
now that we've shown you what's in store
for resident evil village let's take a
look at the exclusive playstation 5 demo
for this demo
players won't be playing as ethan but as
a character we're referring to as the
maiden
unlike the actual game this experience
doesn't feature combat or even blocking
we're hoping to have players get a real
feel for the visuals and audio as they
take the maiden on her journey to find a
way out of the castle and you can
download the exclusive demo on
playstation 5
today
of course we want as many people as
possible to get a chance to play
so we'll have a separate new demo
available on all platforms ready for
sometime this spring